Washington journal continues this is the
book shattered inside Hillary Clinton's
doomed campaign the co-authors Jonathan
Allen Amy Parnes thank you both for
being with us thank you very much let's
go right to it
you both write quote she Hillary had let
President Obama down she had let herself
down she had let her party down and she
had let her country down Obama's legacy
and her dreams of the presidency lay
shattered at Donald Trump's feet this
was on her Amy Parnes we this quote is
from our book in a the end of a chapter
where on election night we take you
inside the peninsula hotel where
Secretary Clinton apologizes to
President Obama and basically this is at
the end of an evening where she thought
she would win she has to say the words
I'm sorry Donald she never thought I
mean congratulations Donald she never
thought she would have to say those
words and here she is saying them she
feels like she has it's a weighty moment
for her you know she's campaigned really
hard she has the president's legacy on
the line she feels like she is the best
person to lead the country and here she
is in defeat yet again in Jonathan Allen
in that moment whom Abidine her longtime
aide has the phone and says it's the
president and it's almost as if Hillary
Clinton paused for a moment she was not
ready to speak to Barack Obama she's
been she's been doing this a long time
she knew what that call meant that this
was the the consolation call from the
President of the United States to talk
to the losing candidate in the
presidential election and she she hears
that the president's on the line and she
doesn't she doesn't want to talk to him
she visibly winces she just kind of
recoils a little bit from it and and
then you know she's able to gather
herself and picks up the phone and sort
of walks away from her aides and says
mr. president I'm sorry and you know
this is it's just sort of a powerful
moment as I was saying that the stakes
were so high in this election Secretary
Clinton had been seeking this office for
so long
you only as Amy said believes that she
was the best person to have this job and
all of this sort of weight is crushing
on her shoulders at the at this one
moment it's you know if you if you have
difficulty feeling sympathy at that
moment just on a human level you know I
think I think if you read the book II
will feel some sympathy for her whether
you like her adult in Amy pardons let's
just focus on election night for just a
moment because we were alive all evening
covering the events as they unfolded
inside the Javits Center there were
pieces of plastic to represent shards of
glass that were going to come down when
Hillary Clinton was about to declare a
victory of course that did not happen
but earlier in the evening Hillary
Clinton campaign staffers were elated
overjoyed excited preparing for a
victory that all began to change at
about ten or eleven o'clock at night and
then at about 1:30 in the morning your
colleague Bob Cusack was on the air with
us after Hillary Clinton had lost
Pennsylvania Michigan and Wisconsin he
said it's over right but my question is
what was happening inside the Clinton
campaign so there were gathered some of
them were in her hotel room at the
Peninsula Hotel in New York some of them
were in a boiler room in Brooklyn others
were in a midtown Manhattan boiler room
they were trying to gather information
very quickly if they knew that things
had started to go wrong when they
started seeing numbers coming in from
Florida and President Clinton was
calling we heard some longtime advisors
down there and getting readouts on what
was happening down on the ground he was
getting word that things didn't look
good
Robby Mook was basically coming in and
giving Secretary Clinton updates they
had hourly calls with staffers at the
same time kind of getting updates and
getting briefings they knew that things
weren't looking good but they still
thought after Florida okay if we can
hang on to North Carolina if we can hang
on to Pennsylvania we have a chance at
this and then things just started
escalating from there and what makes
this different Jonathan Allen is he is
you look at two recent campaigns John
McCain knew he was gonna lose in 2008
Bob Dole knew he was gonna lose in 1996
but in this case Hillary Clinton all
along thought she was going to win the
and I'm gonna think that changed up and
down a little bit depending on what was
going on on the campaign but definitely
in the last few days she was certain she
was gonna win she was talking to AIDS a
lot about governance about what she was
going to do in the White House we
recount in exchange she had with one
with one of her aides a few days before
the election and she said you know I
bring out the worst in a lot of people
and and I don't know why that is but it
is and that the aide says to her you
know that's it's gonna get worse when
you're in the White House and she says
yeah you know somebody who was very much
thinking about going into the presidency
you know that we can't do a justice on
the air here but in the book that
tick-tock of election that we have I
mean you see the the optimism waning and
the reality rising you know through the
course of that night and as Amy said
that the first indications were in
Florida and then the question was are
the numbers that we're seeing in Florida
are the behaviors of the electorate that
we're seeing in Florida are they gonna
extrapolate to North Carolina to
Pennsylvania to Michigan to Wisconsin
and there was some some hope that they
wouldn't that there would be a regional
effect it's just Florida that's behaving
this way but instead what the I think
what they knew in their in their hearts
at least the folks that were familiar
with the data was it was likely that
there were certain parts of Florida
would behave like those other states and
that it was really you have the the
bellwether for what was going to happen
that night and you both write about the
two-year narrative of the campaign I
want to go back to a couple of points
page 228 you write the following
Jonathan Allen as Donald Trump took
control of the Republican race one of
Hillary's longtime advisors circulated a
memo the very top read quote fact Donald
Trump can defeat Hillary and become the
45th President of the United States you
went on to write the advisors memo never
gained traction this is this is somebody
who's got a pretty circumspect you know
view of what's going on in politics and
this memo what was one of the many
Canaries in the coal mine about what was
going to happen
there were people within the Clinton
campaign who believed that there they
had
gotten to God send in the nomination of
Donald Trump and I think even to this
day there were probably a lot of people
who believe that Donald Trump in a
general election was was potentially a
poor choice for Republicans except for
that he ended up winning and you know
this advisor says add three points to
the polls add four points to the polls
every time this guy can win and and
people are you know not reporting
correctly circular file the the memo
went into the circular file at the
campaign never to be heard from again
I think a lot of the people on the
campaign which was very data focused
sort of viewed that as an old schooling
quaint way to look at politics that oh
yeah of course you can just add three or
four points it's Donald Trump without
any evidence whereas I think the advisor
thought you know just had a sense for
what was going on in the country where
the national polls accurate well
probably not because I don't think
anyone saw it coming and it's funny cuz
John and I received a memo from someone
inside the campaign that night and who
basically said just that we never saw
this coming
their internal polling was telling them
something completely different this is
why I think a lot of reporters were
hearing from people inside the campaign
that they were feeling really good about
where they were but but their internal
polling was obviously askew sure I was
just gonna say that you know there's
sort of a couple of different data
points they have the big public polls
that they're looking at which we were
all looking at and I think most people
expect it on election day Hillary
Clinton's gonna win because the polls
all said that she was going to win this
the public polls then internally they do
these data analytics surveys which are
quick horse race questions that the data
team sends out to people across the
country to get a sense of where the
horse races in particular States what
they didn't have going on at the end was
tracking polling if sort of traditional
polling of what people are doing the
last few weeks which some people on the
campaign believed would have been a
check at least on the information they
were getting from from the other sources
and you write about Robby Mook who is a
campaign manager quote his obsession
with control served him well but
colleagues saw his self-interest coming
at the cost of the candidate he had
already begun to develop a reputation
for caring as much about
his own brand in promoting his own
people as he did about Hillary getting
elected one of the stories that we
talked about in this book is basically
how he had responsibilities kind of
taken from him quietly it's never quite
got out during the campaign but there
was the formation of the super six which
key advisors kind of handled various
responsibilities and so we detail a lot
of this in the book but I think you know
there was some infighting we heard that
there were problems in tension a certain
tension with Robbie and John Podesta
that campaign chairman they went away
one time we do tell this in the book we
talk about a retreat that they had where
one called the other passive-aggressive
and it kind of they didn't have there
was no real love loss there I guess you
can say as you know your book is getting
a lot of reaction including from the
Clinton campaign to tweets I want to
share with you Christina Reynolds who
worked for Hillary Clinton the campaign
wasn't easy but don't agree with the
depiction in a new book my take on
Hillary for America and Jessie Ferguson
a veteran of the communication staff
agree 100% we made mistakes we lost but
depiction in book doesn't resemble the
campaign that I saw it's you know what's
fascinating about this book is that
we're telling their story
we interviewed more than a hundred
sources for this book many of them
inside the campaign many of them at the
upper echelons of the campaign so we we
stand by all of our reporting obviously
and and this is their story we didn't
really talk to many Outsiders here it's
basically the inside story of what
happened the title shattered how did
that come about it's interesting we knew
we were gonna do a book on the campaign
and and probably the Hillary Clinton
side of the campaign because we'd
written a previous book HRC as you know
about hurt the State Department in fact
thank you for having us on here to talk
about that book a few years ago when we
first started throwing around possible
titles that there was a question of
what's in the she wings basket and
what's in that she loses basket and is
there anything that works for both and
so very early on shattered was something
we
looked at as something that worked for
both because if she won it would be
about shattering the glass ceiling if
she lost it would be about the sort of
shattered dreams and and then we forgot
about it and you know because we didn't
need a title to write the book and in
fact it was sort of helpful to not have
a title to write the book in terms of
just reporting what we could find in
each moment and this book has moments of
great jubilation inhalation for this
campaign and moments of defeat and
frustration and vexation and all the
things that people live through and I
think some of the excerpts come out and
you lose that there's really a full
fleshy world of this campaign that's in
the book but it was helpful to not have
a title because it allowed us to just
report without rich in conclusion of who
was gonna win and then when she lost we
came back to the question of what the
title should be and very quickly shat we
found shadow to be appealing we thought
that it talked about what happened for
her what happened for the Democratic
Party I mean we thought there were a lot
of levels to that and so that was it was
it was arrived at pretty quickly but I
just want to go back for a second and
say the not having a title was important
because we did all that reporting
without the title without a bias as to
who was gonna win or lose and then once
she lost we didn't have to go back and
tear up chapters we didn't have to go
back and reconstitute a narrative arc
that wasn't accurate we had a lot of the
stuff already written whether she was
going to win or lose
the stories in here would have been the
same the inside story of Hillary
Clinton's doomed campaign and our guest
Jonathan Alan and Amy Parnes let's get
to your phone calls on the Democrats
line al from Hampton Virginia go ahead
please yes good morning c-span and good
morning to your guests and Thank You
c-span for all you two your great
channel and I try to watch you as often
as possible
I don't think Hillary Clinton's loss was
lost Hillary Cohen I think it was a loss
to the nation and I say that because
it's not that she lost is that Donald
Trump won and I'm not so hard
on all the things she didn't do right
her campaign but there was a clear
distinction between the two
and Donald Trump um he showed us that a
nation can be convinced arm that his
rhetoric and the things he was talking
about was just so different then the way
that Hillary Clinton was offering I'm
getting my thoughts all all backed up
let me get your points so out thanks for
the call we'll get a response
Amy Parnes I'm sorry I couldn't hear him
very well talking about how it was
Donald Trump who won the election
Hillary Clinton didn't lose it
right I think that's a very fair point I
think she did lose and he did win and
when people ask us that question and say
did she lose her win I mean did he win
or did she lose I think it's both
obviously people were obviously taken by
surprise that he did win but I think
what we detail in this book is basically
you know how she lost and how it was so
much more how so many factors played in
to her loss that it wasn't just Russia
and Comey that it was this tension in
the campaign that the lack of a message
which we detailed pretty early on from
the very start of her campaign she was
having messaging issues she brought in
lots of advisors to help her on her
Roosevelt Island speech there was no
core message there will be stuffy at
that point is that that was one of the
the court mistakes of the Kennedy
campaign if you remember back in 1980
Roger Mudd asking him why do you want to
be President he could not answer that
question right right and that was sort
of a problem for her in 2008 and one
that a lot of people thought that she
would have learned but there was a wall
in Brooklyn
that basically had a Hillary is four and
there were post-it notes all over and it
became Hillary's for everything and when
your for everything your really for
nothing and you know people knew what
Donald Trump was about he had a very
simple message he wanted to make America
great again
she kind of you know went from message
to message he started with breaking
barriers she ended up you know that was
one um then she ended up with stronger
together I'm with her people didn't
really know what was
and they couldn't differentiate and and
I think a lot of people still inside the
campaign couldn't tell you why she was
running and we actually one of our
chapters chapter 1 is basically said I'd
have a reason for running basically if I
if I ran let me go back that's what one
of our senior aides said if I could just
sure in terms of if you're for
everything you're not for anything it's
not to say that Hillary Clinton wasn't
for anything because she was for so many
things but she it was so hard for voters
to figure out what was the priority and
with regard to I'm with her you write on
pages 319 and 320 the following quote in
late September of 2016 Clinton
consultants reached out to their Sanders
campaign consultants to ask for Bernie's
time and a share the script of an ad the
final words on that ad I'm with her were
too much it's so phony
senator Sanders griped I don't want to
say that yeah he thought her tagline was
was disingenuous or phony as he put it
this is a moment in September 2016 where
the Clinton people know that they still
haven't brought in the full Bernie
coalition and and that they want to have
that to win and they probably needed to
win or at least more than they had so
they reach out to these consultants say
we need senator Sanders cut out an ad
senator Sanders had said to her he would
do anything he was called upon to do so
he decided to cut the ad and that was
just a bridge too far for him what's
interesting is sort of a coda to that
Steve is that the Clinton people he so
he had cut the whole ad without that the
Clinton people looked at it they asked
for some changes to it Bernie's people
made some changes the Clinton people
sent it to focus groups and the focus
groups came back saying they thought
that Bernie Sanders was either
articulating his own message or that he
was disingenuous about his support for
Hillary Clinton they didn't believe him
and so the Clinton people based on the
focus group data decided that they
weren't going to run this ad broadcast
that they that they basically would chop
it up and do some digital ads based on
the targeted to various groups but they
weren't gonna run at broadcast which
with some people we spoke to thought was
a mistake that the that they should have
ignored what they were hearing in the
focus groups and actually run it because
it might have might have had an effect a
positive effect on bringing some of the
Bernie people back into the Democratic
camp Jim good morning from Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania Republican line good
morning guys
a couple quick remarks and I I got a
suggestion for another book first of all
it worked Clinton laws she came across
as a shrill old lady bitter I mean
that's one of the reasons and some of
the remarks he made about the voters and
I think people just got tired of seeing
her and no matter think people forget
you take away California New York she
loses by five million votes suggested
for a book is on Elizabeth Warren it
should be interesting
you know she claimed the big part
American native in India and whatever
with and then she isn't and she ended up
getting a position in our university
over somebody deserve a job the other
think she's a multi-millionaire from
sewing houses I mean this would be a
great book on her but you guys did a
good job on that book I seen you a
couple times and it's a good book I'm
gonna try to buy it so I want to thank
you for that thank you any parts
response it's funny I can't hear the
colors for him I will fix on that yeah
just mama let's go to a christina and
oakland michigan good morning and thank
you allowing me to speak on c-span and i
watched this man a lot
I watched hearings i watch everything
under the sun please just give me a
couple minutes to do to complete my my
god
hillary clinton had our tax money
already in all these series but benghazi
and everything else they were the
republican party was already running
against her bernie sanders I've known
about Bernie Sanders for years I never
heard him talk about being president his
political revolution should have started
back in 2010 and Bernie Sanders was
getting pretty sandy to all the kids and
he what are the kids want
so everybody emotionally
oh we don't like Hilary and yet this
nation you ought to look at the voters
because a snake oil salesman who lies on
today still lies got elected president
Christina thank you you could sense her
passion I was gonna say she should have
her own show I feel like there was that
there was a good a good bit of stuff in
there too like dissect you know the cars
right that Hillary Clinton was the
subject of a tremendous Republican
effort to defeat her from the Benghazi
hearings through talking about the
Clinton Foundation and the email server
and the but that's all I mean that is
always true that the candidate of a
party is sought and the other side seeks
to undermine them the the whole idea is
to win despite that you know there were
oddities in this election the Russian
attempt to interfere in the election the
how FBI director Jim Comey dealt with
his job but you know I think if you go
back to what amy was saying before
there's there are issues with the sort
of core issues about what Hillary
Clinton was running for as she said her
seat at one of the Clinton senior
advisors said I would have had a reason
for running or I wouldn't have run this
is one of her senior advisors this is
not somebody that you know the outskirts
of the campaign or just some random
voter these are people who were inside
saying we don't know what the core
message is that we need to fold
everything else into that's a huge
problem for a campaign that helps set
the stage to be to be defeated later if
you talk about the the Jim Comey stuff
none of that would have happened without
a private email server that you know
that brought the FBI to investigate her
and whether or not you think that
there's a criminally prosecute Abul
action in there by Secretary Clinton the
FBI determined there wasn't you would
have to investigate a few of the FBI the
release of classified information
outside the classified system so a lot
of these issues can sort of be drawn
back to things that Hillary Clinton did
or fail to do which is the headline this
morning Amy Parnes front page of the New
York Times in trying to avoid politics
the FBI director James Comey shaped an
election very early in your book you
write extent
easily about the server the email server
that was discovered and I want to share
with our audience how Hillary Clinton
responded at the United Nations and then
get your insights into what was
happening inside the campaign this is
from 2015 when I got to work as
Secretary of State I opted for
convenience to use my personal email
account which was allowed by the State
Department because I thought it would be
easier to carry just one device for my
work and for my personal emails instead
of two looking back it would have been
better if it I simply used a second
email account and carried a second phone
but at the time this didn't seem like an
issue I did not email any classified
material to anyone on my email there is
no classified material so I'm certainly
well aware of the classification
requirements and did not send classified
material amy pond's you write about this
in your book the issue specifically and
the larger narrative more generally
dogged her until Election Day oh yeah I
mean this is early March 2015 and she
hadn't even officially launched her
campaign yet and here she is already
talking about it and then you know fast
forward to the summer of 2015 just
they're trying to get you know she's
launched her speech in Roosevelt Island
they can't get their message through the
email cloud is hanging over Brooklyn and
there's a sense of frustration happening
there she and her husband are getting
frustrated because they feel like their
aides aren't kind of getting their
message across her aides want her to
some of them want her to apologize and
so there's this like push-pull going on
about how to handle the issue internally
and eventually why that why the drip
drip drip why not try to get ahead of
the story at some point I think they
genuinely feel like she didn't do
anything wrong as she said here in this
clip they felt like you know they had
been above level that they didn't need
to apologize that it would only add kind
of fuel to the fire and and so I think
that's where they were
I think her she was advised
not to do that that she but we should
just you know they should come forward
and you know move on and then and then
in September you know she's still
dealing with it going into the fall post
in that kind of post Labor Day rush
that's something that's a place where
they didn't want to be at the time and
it's interesting you played that clip
she said I did not email any classified
information there is no classified email
that turns out to not be true it's one
of the things that hurts for credibility
she's not apologizing for that for the
for the entirety of that summer of 2015
she said that she did this for
convenience so she would have one device
instead of two of course from Abadie and
her closest aide carried her devices and
there were multiple devices a lot of the
pieces of the story that she told that
the UN there turned out to not be true
and and threw into question with a lot
of voters I think her credibility
certainly those who already didn't like
her saw that as evidence I think someone
you know in the middle obviously we saw
those dishonesty numbers rise to you
know catastrophic levels for her I think
part of the problem is that there were
two tracks there was a legal track and a
political track and what you would do on
the legal track is different than what
you would do you know sort of best
advice for what you would say
politically I think she needed to be
careful about what she was saying
there was a point at which John Podesta
her campaign Chairman hadn't wanted to
just put all the emails from her State
Department time out into the public
because he thought that would be like
let's get ahead of this
that would have been disastrous had they
done it because it turned out that there
was classified information and those
emails had they done that they probably
all would have been prosecutable by the
FBI so or by the Justice Department so I
think she was in a sort of in a box of
how to do things in the way that was
best for her legally and best for her
politically you write in the book and I
mentioned any pardons the overall
narrative of how she was viewed among
the electorate you say on one level it
should not have been surprising if the
official political arm of the Democratic
Party was more supportive of Hillary
against an outsider who was reluctant to
even run as a member of the party on
another however though it was proof
positive that two Sanders supporters
senator Bernie Sanders
to clinton's critics that hillary was an
establishment creature who rigged
political outcomes and I think that
actually hurt her because they it was
kind of a narrative that followed her
into the general election where they
couldn't they thought that you know they
were behind a movement that she was just
kind of the inevitable candidate the
party backed candidate and and that
became an issue for her I think it
loomed over her campaign the entire time
and and you know we talked to people who
basically felt like the Sanders you know
there was this resentment in Clinton
land that assay that Sanders hadn't
conceded earlier had him backed out of
the primary earlier that he had dragged
us on he had kind of damaged her her you
know narrative and that he had sort of
said that she's working in cahoots with
big banks and that was a narrative that
she couldn't kind of overcome in general
and and that's another one that they say
hurt her in November and Jonathan Allen
you go on to right quote inside of the
Washington bubble Bernie had long been
looked at as a revolutionary without
much of a Fallujah nary without much of
a following and yet as perhaps the most
reliable liberal voice in Congress he
had built a following among progressives
who caught campaign clips of him on
c-span thank you for the plug we had to
plug that but you also say the
uncompromising and incorruptible style
was precisely the reason he was poised
to take advantage of a popular
Renaissance in the electorate yeah I
mean it's really amazing I mean it you I
won't ask you to comment on this but
you've been watching Bernie Sanders here
in Congress from more than a quarter of
a century I don't think anybody would
have I wish I said we did an interview
with him in 1990 he said the same thing
in 1990 that he was saying in 2016 right
the exact same things the the
consistency is unbelievable and nobody
in Washington listened to Bernie Sanders
for the first twenty five years and when
he announced his candidacy for the
presidency I think everybody in
Washington looked at and thought you're
crazy you you've accomplished very
little on a legislative scale here you
don't have a lot of friends in
Washington there's no way that you're
going to be able
to win a party nomination and the
presidency or even be competitive and by
the way who the heck's ever heard of you
and as it turns out the fact that Bernie
Sanders was so distant from the
Washington establishment the fact that
he wasn't somebody who had this long
list of legislative accomplishments
wasn't somebody that was getting praised
by the other side of the aisle or even
his own side of the aisle to the extent
that you would consider Democrats his
side of the aisle because even with the
Democratic Party that he largely votes
with he still wants the distance of
calling himself an independent you know
because of all of those things people
here looked at him and said there's no
way all of those things made him look
much more appealing to folks outside of
Washington and that helped him catch a
fire and I think you know part of that
was there's a piece of the Democratic
Party that has always been less
comfortable with the Clintons not like
the Clintons as much they'll vote for
him in the general election but not not
excited about them in primaries I think
he's able to grab some of that I think
was waiting out there for him or
Elizabeth Warren or anybody else right
but I also think Bernie Sanders is a
pretty good job of articulating some of
the things that populist in the
Democratic Party outside the Democratic
Party even some of the Republican Party
thought were problems with the
establishment though certainly the
income disparities that we've seen in
this country and and the you know the
power that certain institutions have so
I wouldn't have predicted it I'm pretty
sure Amy wouldn't have predicted it
maybe there were few c-span viewers who
paid attention where over the years it
would have viewed it but the other thing
is when they'll press predicted it will
press is is in this book and there's a
sort of good anecdote in there about
Bernie
you know first consulting with him
before deciding to run but you know
there's this this thing that happens
where Bernie goes ahead and runs and I
call Bernie senator Sanders I goes ahead
and runs and he's able to contrast with
Secretary Clinton so well because he has
been such this iconoclast over the years
because he's been saying the same thing
on c-span since 1990 he's got this
credibility and her big problem or one
of her big problems is that is this
credibility issue and that she's you
know in different places will usually
she negotiates the
trade the TPP trans-pacific partnership
and then comes out against it and as we
write in the book even when she comes
out against it she says she doesn't say
this is the worst thing that ever
happened it's terrible we shouldn't do
it she says these are the conditions
under which I could support the TPP
we're just not there yet so he has this
nice contrast point of ideological
purity that I think the the outside was
looking for because they get tired of
hearing politicians tell them one thing
one day and another thing next that sort
of kind of talks to this where Secretary
Clinton is on a plane with her close
aide longtime advisor mignon Moore and
she's trying to basically wrap her mind
around the rise of populism that's
happening around her and she doesn't
quite understand what's going on and she
said you know she's basically in a
heart-to-heart conversation post no New
Hampshire is having this talk where she
she doesn't understand and I think that
actually speaks to it's a great passage
in the book that kind of talks to where
her mind was what she was thinking in
that moment that she wasn't quite she
knew she wasn't connecting with voters
and and she wanted to know why if you're
listening on c-span radio or we welcome
our listeners on Sirius XM the POTUS
channel 124 which carries us every
Sunday our two guests Jonathan Allen and
Amy Parnes co-authors of shattered
inside Hillary Clinton's doomed campaign
Rose thank you for waiting Nashville
Tennessee Republican line good morning
good morning thank you for c-span and
thank you for having these guests on and
I do intend to get your book I just
wanted I just have to kind of chuckle a
little bit about the polls and the
pollsters they all predicted a Hillary
win but I've been a trump supporter from
the very beginning I'm so thankful he's
our president we knew that Donald Trump
was going to win because for especially
the older voters we we have a history
with Hillary and we know her credibility
gap going way back to whitewater and the
rose law firm and all that but anyway I
my comment is about the polls
now these same pollsters and polls are
telling us that Donald Trump doesn't
have a very good performance rating and
and job performance rating and all that
and I just have to chuckle because these
are the same people that told us that
Hillary was gonna win in this Thank You
rose we'll get a response Rose I think
you make a good point about the polls
they were off a lot of people expected
Hillary Clinton to win who were paying
attention to polls a lot of people who
thought the polls might be off and what
paying as much attention to them thought
Donald Trump was going to win and ended
up being right but you know polls have
have utility but limited utility and we
talked about this you know some in the
book they're not first of all they're
not static public opinion changes so if
you pull something today and it's 47%
it's not necessarily gonna be 47% next
week because events change people change
their minds public opinion is is dynamic
so number one I think you know when
you're looking at polls it's more
important to watch the movement of the
poll necessarily than to attribute a lot
to the baseline obviously if you're in a
political campaign you want to know
where things are and how to change them
where you need to change them but I
think I think watching you know when you
look at Donald Trump's approval rating
what it will be more important on any
given day is how did it move since the
previous day how did it move since the
previous week not necessarily that exact
number because clearly people who do
public opinion research right now are
having difficulty nailing what our our
electorate is feeling and what the
American public is feeling you know and
they're within ranges it's that you know
it's not exactly 48 percent it's like a
a percentage confidence level that it's
48 percent which means it's probably 45
to 50 or so you know take all the grain
of salt I think Rose makes some good
points and please please do buy the book
let us know what you think about it Rose
yes number one right now in amazon.com
Chuck from Phoenix City Alabama
Republican line good morning good
morning first of all I'm 78 years old
and I have a very good memory the
Clintons were nothing more than criminal
it was a criminal activity before they
even left
I can saw these supposedly highly
educated people who are Hillary
supporters go out here they must think
we're all dumb as a rock because
everything that they've ever touched has
been involved with criminal activity
hillary went out here when bill allowed
82 people to be burned alive in waco
which included 25 children hillary had
no outrage these people are totally as
phony as a piece of plastic in your
wallet amy pond's there was there was an
image problem for her going in something
that they tried to remedy around
September of 2015
they knew that with the email
controversy kind of blooming they had to
kind of bring out the Hillary that
people tell us about behind the scenes
you know the one who's really gregarious
and funny and so there was an effort to
really put her on the late-night circuit
put her on The Ellen DeGeneres Show to
sort of to dance and show that lighter
side but I think it's it's something
that they grappled with and and that
actually got a lot of pushback this
effort because it basically there was a
New York Times piece I kind of talked
about it and you know brought it to
surface and it looked kind of contrived
this whole communications effort looked
like they had to package her and and try
to bring her out and you know and
Telegraph that that it was coming out
and I think that annoyed a lot of donors
we were both hearing from them and a lot
of supporters and you know I think even
those inside the campaign called it an
unforced error because I think it was I
think they didn't need to sort of you
know convey that that was part of their
plan and just to address the wake up
situation for a moment it's a long time
ago you know obviously that could have
turned out in a way that was better than
it did turn out for all involved within
the Branch Davidians were stockpiling
weapons that think the plane weighs more
there will go to an oval Pennsylvania
and Mary is next independent line yes
hello I just wanted to say I didn't vote
for Clinton or or Trump but I get so
tired of hearing people say Trump ones
from one people
we're repulsed by his message he lost by
three million popular boo so I'm just
like I'm tired of hearing hell didn't
his agenda won because but it certainly
did not thank you thank you Mary yeah so
true that Hillary Clinton won more more
popular votes and that's one of the
things she did well in this campaign one
of the achievements she had she won more
more votes than any Republican nominee
in American history so that you know
that's a that's a big moment for her and
and I think more votes than any nominee
and history of either party except for
Barack Obama in 2008 and it was very
close with 2012 anyway she won the
popular vote Donald Trump does not have
a huge mandate from the electorate as a
result of this election his electoral
college vote win was small by historical
standards
he lost the popular vote he has claimed
a mandate I think the caller has a point
that this was not a situation where he
was an overwhelmingly popular figure I
think this was a situation where there
were two politicians who had engendered
a lot of anger and disregard from the
public and he happened to to get more
votes in the right places than she did
let's go to rich Pensacola Florida
Democrats lying good morning good
morning thank you taking my call my
question is after on election night
there were stories coming out the next
day that Hillary Clinton had a major
meltdown that night and etc etc and I
was just wondering kind of latest to
residents whether it was true and just
kind of what was her her temperament
after she learned that she lost the
election thank you rich yes thank you
for the question anybody haven't found
any of that to be true we know that
there's that story line out there we
found we interviewed a lot of people in
the room with her and be the word that
they use a stoic to describe her mood
that night most of them did and she
basically as I said earlier would
have advisors come in meet with her give
her the information she needed every
time they told her what was happening
she nodded or gave a very short reply
and I guess was trying to process it all
but if far as any anger that night or
you know the reports of her throwing
things and we haven't found any of that
to be true and we did a pretty deep dive
and talked to a lot of people in that
room I think like everyone she was
really she it's actually a very
humanizing moment I think this chapter
is one that everyone can identify with
because it was a shocking moment for her
she expected the ending to be completely
different
she was absorbing it she wanted to
actually take time to write a concession
speech that spoke to her campaign and
and a lot of people arguably said it was
her best speech of the campaign because
it struck the right note you know it
basically talked about there were some
people in her camp that wanted her to go
out guns blazing and basically say that
you know Donald Trump you know it's the
devil and and you know but she took the
diplomatic approach she wanted to be
very conciliatory she wanted to address
her supporters and that moment and how
they could and and kind of charted a
path to the future - I went back to that
moment in a moment but I want to go back
to two earlier points in the campaign
Jonathan Allen first of all the
selection of Tim Kaine I'm gonna
paraphrase but you write that while a
solid choice not a lot of enthusiasm for
Tim Kaine that's right there's a point
where Secretary Clinton is going through
her options and and she's telling what
the tongue of advisors uh she doesn't
like him she doesn't like the options
that she feels like they're lackluster
she's looking at senator cane she's
looking at Tom Vilsack the agriculture
secretary under President Obama who's
who she adores I mean these are people
that she likes she's looking at Cory
Booker the senator from New Jersey and
she's just you know she tells him that
she just doesn't like the options this
is like weeks out from making the
decision which is actually the birth
through which Elizabeth Warren the
senator from Massachusetts makes a
rapid ascent of the shortlist you know I
think there were a lot of people thought
that would never happen because senator
Warren had written some bad stuff about
Secretary Clinton in a book before and
Senator Warren you know had some clashes
with the Obama White House and you know
there was this thought that she wouldn't
be as pragmatic and Secretary Clinton
you know really prides herself on
pragmatism in policymaking and being you
know having a real deep handle on the
substance and Senator Warren is somebody
who understands all the substance and
sometimes understands the political
moment too and will back back away and
take that stand and that can be
interpreted as her not the White House
will sometimes you know or the Obama
White House would sometimes push back
and say well she doesn't really
understand this feeling she understands
it but she also gets how to have it make
a political issue so the two women meet
they actually start talking policy they
get really deep into the weeds they are
connecting Secretary Clinton basically
decides you know it gets into her mind
like this is actually somebody that I
could you know conceivably work with
senator woman goes out on the campaign
trail does some some surrogate work
essentially for for Secretary Clinton
and and they're getting closer to a
place where that might happen there's a
debate internally in the campaign it's
two women a problem or does to women
double down on the on the you know the
change nature of Hillary Clinton which
is something Clinton had difficulty
saying you know that she was going to be
a change candidate she was a physical
representation of change in terms of her
gender but other than that didn't have a
lot to offer in terms of change so some
people like that some people didn't but
the the bottom line is Secretary Clinton
didn't feel like she'd had enough of a
background at least this is what our
sources tell us didn't have enough of a
background of transactions with Senator
Warren to really fully trust that
Senator Warren was going to be always a
partner and and never a thorn in her
side if she was the vice president and
all of this goes to this you know
something that might have been a failure
on the part of the campaign which is and
the candidate which is that they were
thinking about who's the best governing
partner not who can help me win there's
another moment I want to talk about it
in just a moment on the debate but first
here's Diane joining us from Minnesota
Republican line
morning good morning Steve thank you for
letting me say what I want to say you're
not talking about her health we all
watched her collapse on live TV and she
had health issues you're not talking
about that issue on the table so let's
address it right now thanks for putting
that out there
there was a little bit of annoyance this
when she had her when she fell on
September 11th of last year people there
was a delay in response and people on
the campaign were quick to blame people
like Huma Abedin for not communicating
what was happening you know these are
critical moments this is the final
stretch of the campaign that that fall
was seen on loop all day and then you
know in the weeks after and I think they
had a hard time kind of communicating
that and telling people what was going
on and that kind of you know it fed into
the whole distrust issue and and the
fact that you know people the Clintons
are hiding things and I think that
didn't work to her favor obviously let's
go to Jack in Champaign Illinois
independent line good morning good
morning then thanks for Steve and I
watch you guys a lot on a woman asked to
guess if I recall I remember seeing you
on another program and you were talking
about the background information when
you collected it and then you promised
people to you know that you wouldn't
release the information and or go public
or write the book until after the
election could you talk about when you
guys collected the information I thought
that was pretty interesting thank you
thank you jack any part we reached an
agreement pretty early on with our
sources we had written another book hrc
as we mentioned earlier we knew a lot of
these people really well from our first
book and obviously in in DC and in
campaigns you don't want you don't want
the real story to get out particularly
before the election because you know
there's a lot going on so we were
writing this book we came to an
agreement with a lot of our sources that
with every one of our sources really
pretty much that they could basically
tell us
what was on their mind be as candid our
goal here was to get the most accurate
the most candid story and so we felt
like this gave them a little bit of
leeway to be able to do that and because
Jack you know the during the campaign if
these things come out you know they're
bumpy moments there are ugly moments
that you know these folks don't want
don't want to affect the outcome of the
campaign so you know not only do we have
the promise that they would be kept on
background meaning that we would not
identify the source by their name in the
book but also that we promised them that
we would not publish anything until
after the election and we thought that
was the only way that these folks would
talk to us because otherwise they could
be telling us things that we might
report and that would affect the outcome
and that would make them not talk to us
and the reason this is important in
getting the whole story is we didn't
have to wait until after the election to
talk to people and to start getting a
feel for what was going on inside the
campaign we've been doing that since you
know late 2014 and sometimes people were
talking to us more and sometimes people
were talking to us less certainly right
before the election there was a little
bit of a freeze you know everybody was
nervous and fewer people wanted to talk
but because we were able to get some so
much of that information before the
election it was helpful to be able to
take the measure of what was going on in
March of 2015 and in August of 2015 and
February 2016 and match it against what
people were saying after the election
because when they start talking about
what happened before once the election
has happened you get the sanitized
version and and that's not to say
anything bad about the people that
you're talking to it's that memories
fade over time it is that there is a
political necessity or demand in terms
of trying to spin the narrative of what
happened in the campaign the right way
and we certainly have seen that after
the election by both sides we've seen
Donald Trump's win the election the way
that he wants to we've seen you know
we've seen folks who were supportive of
Secretary Clinton spin it the way they
want to and so you know we think it was
important to get that that story early
the very first debate campus of Hofstra
University in Long Island New York let's
watch but this is a man who has called
women pigs
slobs and dogs and
someone who has said pregnancy is an
inconvenience to employers who has said
women don't deserve equal pay unless
they do as good a job as men and one of
the worst things he said was about a
woman in a beauty contest
he loves beauty contests supporting them
and hanging around them and he called
this woman Miss Piggy then he called her
Miss Housekeeping because she was latina
Donald she has a name where did you fart
named Machado where did you phone she
has become a US citizen and you can bet
a real she's going to vote that's know
voce good any parents that was one of
the many moments in the debates last
year how did she prepare for the debate
in your reaction to to that one moment
she prepared with an aide Philippe
rhinos who is a longtime communications
advisor for her one of her most trusted
aides I think he did a pretty stand-up
job for her because she came in really
prepared that's the thing about her in
these moments she's she's really she
comes in knowing everything she's a
policy wonk she's very detail-oriented
but in this particular moment we learned
that in debate prep they actually were
preparing for this someone kind of did
the research about Alicia Machado and
basically brought that out made it a
point to to to do that during the debate
and and they were if this was a very
tale in kind of moment if I recall and
so she did she was successful in that
and that kind of drove their narrative
the next few days and kind of branding
Trampas you know a misogynist and
someone who you know basically didn't
wasn't portrayed in the best light and
it created this sort of firestorm in
Republican circles too because if your
recall Trump goes out after that debate
starts tweeting nasty thanks Felicia
Machado and starts fighting with Alicia
bachata the woman that Secretary was
Clinton speaking of and the reaction
from the real Trump insiders knew the
presence
president now president himself and and
his really in our circle was we're gonna
fight her and they you know they called
some you know video that she had on a
soap opera you know a sex tape and they
you know they were trying to basically
undermine her credibility through a
variety of ways and fat shaming [ __ ]
shaming I mean there was a like really a
terrible terrible moment there and that
the Republican National Committee and
among the Republican surrogates there
was nobody wanted to touch that nobody
wanted to get into beating up on this
woman who Donald Trump had wronged you
know in the past and there was really
tension between his camp and and other
Republicans about what to do about that
nobody nobody wanted to defend him there
and you know some of his closest aides
ended up you know sort of dressing down
some of the Republican officials saying
you better get on board and do this and
they thought it was just terrible
policies and it probably was Donald
Trump won the election despite that not
because of it well go to date Anchorage
Alaska Republican line good morning with
our two authors the book is called
shattered go ahead Dave yeah I actually
have read the book and I worked in the
campaign on the local level up here and
I think one of two things that I would
like to hear about is a I haven't really
heard you talk about what was actually
in the emails that were hacked
especially talking about the pleura
Buhl's
talking about Sanders people that
supported him and a second thing is we
would actually call in to talk shows and
read from those emails and it had had an
effect up here I have many friends in
West Virginia where I'm originally from
and a lot of the union's who dig stuff
build stuff non-governmental unions were
really upset with her especially when
she blow into West Virginia and start
talking about welfare instead of getting
us back into an industrial boat and
getting getting them going I'd like to
hear your
on that day thank you well I think
number one she did have problems with
Union voters there were issues
throughout the country with with Union
voters who even when there sometimes
when their national unions were pushing
them to vote for her you know they would
they would show up and vote for Donald
Trump so I that was an issue broadly in
terms of reading from the emails I think
it was you know you had those John
Podesta emails that came out and they I
think the public conflated the Podesta
emails with the WikiLeaks hack of the
DNC emails with Hillary Clinton's
private server emails it was like the
word email contained so much so much
toxicity for Secretary Clinton and I
think the Republicans understood that
and not only understood have repressed
it as he was saying that call in and
start reading out John potestas emails
on the air that's that's something that
makes people think when they're hearing
it there's something bad in there
regardless of how bad the content
actually is I mean it says none of this
was good for Secretary Clinton and all
of it was a reminder of the original
email scandal although I will say that
they felt like her the release of her
personal emails it was actually shed
light on her you know lighter moments
and that she liked various shows and
they were actually happy when I talked
to aides to to kind of reveal those
moments so I think those those were good
moments for her maybe two other moments
and there's so much in this book but you
talked about the vice president with an
eye on 2020 if he considers to run
Vice President Biden you say was annoyed
that the media focused so much attention
on Hillary and her second bid for the
presidency when he was sitting in plain
sight in the White House as months
ripped off the calendar
he remained unsure inside the Clinton
campaign though the threat of a Biden
campaign was a mounting concern oh yeah
there was a moment in the fall we're
going into the fall where they actually
thought that he could do some damage and
there was an effort the Biden folks felt
like to box him in and and to not give
him much of a runway into the campaign
and he was really annoyed by that and he
voiced his frustration to advisers and
donors around him
and we detail some of that in the book
there were there was a great frustration
there even though I know that their
their clothes they've known each other a
long time obviously a former colleagues
but there's feelings of President Obama
- who you know didn't jump in both feet
for Hillary Clinton but certainly was
perceived to prefer her for the
presidential run and and did nothing to
disabuse people of that perception you
know Biden and Clinton as we write got
to a place where if they'd run against
each other I think both sides thought it
was going to get very very personal very
very fast so let me conclude with really
where we began you wrote the following
high above Times Square disbelief
stifled the once a boisterous boiler
boiler room Jonathan Allen it fell quiet
a new reality took hold short of divine
reprieve Hillary was going to lose this
is this amazing moment for all of these
people that literally went to work that
morning thinking they were about to win
the presidency and they would be
celebrating that night and as they're
getting information and from the field
as they're getting you know voting
information anecdotal information what's
going on at the polls from people there
they're watching those dreams chatter in
front of them and you know it's it's
really a shocking stunning you know and
for the folks who were involved in that
campaign heartbreaking moment and I
think for a lot of people in the
Democratic Party a heartbreaking moment
and it's the culmination of so many
things that led to it and that's what
this book is about like what we're did
how did how did this candidate who was
seen as the favorite to become the
president of the United States for the
entirety of her on right there was never
a time where people thought Bernie
Sanders was the favorite in the primary
there was never really a time where
Donald Trump eclipsed Terr but for but
for half a second in the polls in you
know in the general election this is the
story of how that candidate ended up
losing from from A to Z and the next day
after election day Hillary Clinton said
this I know I know we have still not
shattered that highest and hardest glass
ceiling but someday someone will and
hopefully
sooner than we might think right now
[Music]
and
and to all the little girls who are
watching this never doubt that you are
valuable and powerful and deserving of
every chance and opportunity in the
world to pursue and achieve your own
dreams the day after the election
Hillary Clinton conceding to Donald
Trump and Amy Parnes first what's with
the purple so that sources told us was a
suit she was gonna wear the night before
I purple as a unity color I guess she
wanted to convey that kind of message we
know that she wore these white pants
suits for a reason she's very she plans
this out I guess it's safe to say but
you know that it is a powerful speech
and one that she wasn't quite ready to
give the night before and we detail in
the book how she worked with two speech
writers to kind of set the right tone
they were up all night kind of working
to get there they deliver her a draft in
the morning they're still working on it
up until you know and there's a scramble
actually to get hurt there was no place
to actually give the concession speech
so her aides at the same time were
scrambling to find a place and this is
all you know as they're kind of
processing what's going on and one of
the worst days of their lives do you
have a third book for both of you not to
announce yet
Jonathan Allen Amy Parnes the book is
titled shattered inside Hillary
Clinton's doomed campaign to both of you
thank you very much for being with us we
appreciate it thank you Steve well it's
a back to work week for Congress and
we're gonna open our phone lines to get
your thoughts about the to-do list
including keeping the federal government
in operation beyond Friday 2:02 is the
area code seven four eight eight
thousand one that's our line for
Republicans in 202 seven four eight
eight thousand for Democrats for
independence 202 seven four eight eight
thousand two we'll take a short break
we're back in a moment for the Sunday
a third edition of the walk